يوم الم في فلسطين اشتباكات تودي بحياه
تسعه اشخاص بجنين بعد ما هزت حادثته
الشارع السعودي القتل تعذيرا لحارق بندر
القرادي اسبانيه تدخل موسوعه غينيسكا اكبر
معمره على قيد الحياه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث اودت
الاشتباكات العنيفه مع القوات الاسرائيليه
في مخيم جنين
بينهم سيده مسنه واوقعت عشرين عصابه بينها
اربعه بحاله خطيره وكانت القوات
الاسرائيليه اقتحمت مدينه جنين ومخيمها
شمال الضفه الغربيه
واعتلت اسطح المنازل في المخيم ما ادى الى
اندراع مواجهات اطلق خلالها الجنود
الرصاصه وقنابل الغاز باتجاه الشباك فيما
افادت معلومات بان عشرات المرضى في مستشفى
جنين الحكومي بينهم اطفال اصيبوا
بالاختناق نتيجه اطلاق الجيش قنابل الغاز
الموسيقي للدموع داخل المستشفى بشكل مباشر
بعد مرور شهر ونصف على المحاكمه في قضيه
مقتل الشاب السعودي بندر القرادي على يد
صديقه حرقا اعلن اليوم الحكم على الجانب
القتل تحديدا وفي اول تعليق له بعد فطور
الحكم قال طه القردي والد المغدور الحمد
لله حكم على الجانب القصاص وهذا حق الله
والعدل في هذه البلاد الطيبه
فيما كانت شرطه محافظه جده قد اعتقلت
نهايه شهر ديسمبر الماضي مواطنا لاضراره
النار في مركبه ادى الى وفاه قائدها
متاثرا بحروقه اخرى سابق بينهما في حادثه
هزت الشارع السعودي لي فجاهتها
في اكتشاف ان وصف بالمذهله اعلن عالم
الاثار المصري زاهي حواس عن العثور على
اثار عده تعود الى عصر الاسرتين الخامسه
والسادسه في الدوله المصريه القديمه في
منطقه سقاره بالجيزه وخلال مؤتمر صحفي
اوضح حواس ان هذا الكشف ضم مجموعه من
المقابر وتواميد وموميات مشيرا الى ان
الاكتشافات تضمنت 9 تماثيل من الحجر
الجيري الملون وتمثل تماثيل الخدم وتماثيل
منفرده ولم يعثر على ايه نقوش تشير الى
اسم صاحب هذه التماثيل الا ان بابا وهميا
عثر عليه بجوار موقع التماثيل يشير الى ان
صاحبه يدعى ميسي
بعد وفاه الراهبه الفرنسيه لوسيل راندون
البالغه من العمر 118 عاما دخلت ماريا
براند نياس موريرا موسوعه جينيس للارقام
القياسيه كاكبر معمره على قيد الحياه في
العالم هي اسبانيه الجنسيه ولدت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفقا لبيانات
جنس فان ماريا من مواليد العام
1907 تبلغ من العمر حاليا 115 عاما
و328 يوما لديها ثلاثه ابناء واحد 10
حفيدا وثلاثه عشر من ابناء الاحفاد في
مقاله السيده العجوز بتغريد على تويتر
انها متفاجئه وممتنه للاهتمام الذي ولدته
ان تصبح اكبر شخص على قيد الحياه في
العالم
وفي خبرنا الاخير عثر عمال الموانئ في
ماليزيا على صبيا من غلي اختبا سته ايام
في حاويه
نقلت وغادرت ميناء مدينه شات بونج
البنغاليه الى ميناء كلانس في ماليزيا
الشرطه الماليزيه اوضحت في بيان ان الصبي
كان يلعب الغميضه مع اصدقائه في الميناء
البنغالي واختباء داخل الحاويه حاويه نقل
بحري وانتب توفى بداخلها مشيره الى انه
عندما استيقظ وجد نفسه محبوسا بداخلها
وحاول الاستنجاد لكن احدا لم يسمعه فقد
فيها ايامه السد دون طعام او شراب حتى وصل
الى ميناء كلاج فيما تم التواصل مع ذوي
لاعادته الى بلاده ومنزله قريبه
[موسيقى]